Do you remember the concepts we studied in
the previous lesson?
First, we
understood that OPAQUE objects do not allow
light to pass through them.
Second, TRANSPARENT objects allow light to
pass through them and we can see
through them clearly.
And third, TRANSLUCENT objects allow light
to pass through
them partially.
Now I want you to answer this question!
What kind of an object is human body?
Are we able to see THROUGH it?
Not really!
Hence a human body is an OPAQUE
object!
What happens when light is obstructed by the
human body?
We see that the human body is obstructing
light here!
There is light in front of the
human body but what do you see behind it?
Yes, a SHADOW.
This thing you see behind the body is called
a shadow!
Now looking at this, can you tell me the things
that are required for a shadow to
be formed?
Two things are obvious.
First: a source of light, which is in front
of the body.
And second: an opaque
object… here the human body is the opaque
object.
Can you identify any other thing we may need
for a shadow?
Maybe not.
Now let
us consider a different situation.
[Same person standing in open area against
some natural environment such as
sea or open fields, but source of light is
low so that shadow is not seen]
In this situation too, we have a source of
light as well as an opaque body.
But, do
we see a shadow?
NO we don’t.
Do you know why?
Perplexed?
Well, had there been a screen behind the opaque
object, you would
have seen the shadow on it.
But because there is no SCREEN or SURFACE
like in
the previous case, we cannot see the shadow.
What does this tell us?
It tells us that we also need a SURFACE on
which a shadow can be formed.
That
surface will make us see the shadow!
What’s so special about shadows?
Shadows also give us some information about
the object!
So if I show you this
shadow, you will be able to tell me that it’s
a human body’s shadow!
But sometimes they can also be misleading!
For instance, can you name the body
of which this is a shadow?
You’d probably say it’s that of a dog,
but it’s just our
human hands playing the trick!
3 of 3
Has it ever occurred to you as to why shadows
are formed?
We know one of the reasons!
Opaque bodies do not allow light to pass through
them.
Yes that’s one of the main reasons why shadows
are formed!
Another
important reason for shadows to form is that
LIGHT TRAVELS IN A STRAIGHT LINE.
We will see its use in our next lesson.